-Many of us this year
have had to adjust
to new working conditions,
which in a lot of cases
includes working remotely,
and while I can appreciate
we're still learning
to navigate this,
recently, one of my writers,
Mike Scollins,
committed the cardinal sin
of working from home --
he wore a tank top
to a Zoom meeting.
Here to talk about it is
that writer -- Mike Scollins
Mike, how you doing?
-I've been better.
-Is it because we made fun
of you relentlessly
for wearing a tank top on Zoom
-What happened to me was not
making fun.
It was an assault.
-Was it really that bad?
-I don't know.
Let's see an artist's renderin
of the day in question.
I don't remember my arms being
quite that scrawny.
Thanks a lot,
graphics department.
-I mean, I wouldn't say
it's inaccurate.
-Okay, just take it down.
I'd like to run through a list
of my so-called friends on staff
and see what they have to say.
This is head writer Alex Baze.
When I explained I was
wearing a tank top
'cause I thought I was
in the Zoom waiting room,
he said, "Do you mean the Zoom
weight room?"
-Oh, that's a great burn.
-They're all great burns.
The quality of the burns
is not what this is about.
This is Karen Chee.
She's 4'11", but turns out
she can still dunk on me.
When I defended the tank
and said I thought it was nice
she said,
"If you like it so much,
why'd you cut the sleeves off?
-Good one, Chee.
-Well, guess what, Karen?
You went to Harvard,
and I went to Manhattan College,
and we have the same job.
Now who makes bad decisions?
-I mean, she got the job,
like, right out of
college though.
-Bryan Donaldson,
shown here in a screen gra
from "To Catch a Predator" said,
"If you like it so much,
why didn't you buy
the rest of it?"
It's the only question
he's ever asked besides,
"Have you tried resetting
the router?"
Mike Shoemaker.
-Oh, come on, that is not
-Similar vibe though.
Similar vibe.
Ally Hord.
She texted, "Getting attacke
is the pits,"
a clear reference
to my visible armpit hair.
-Ally Hord from the top rope
-Be glad it was over Zoom, Ally,
'cause I use
Tom's of Maine deodorant, an
the way it works is, it doesn't.
Also, if you're wondering wh
she's smiling in that photo,
it was taken the minute sh
found out Tom Hanks had COVID.
-That is not true.
-Sounds true though.
Next! Amber Ruffin!
She decided to take my tank to
burns national.
Let's see what she had to say.
-I'm not going to name names
but obviously someone --
-Mike Scollins!
-Showed up on Zoom
in a tank top.
-[ Laughs ]
-You were supposed to be
promoting your show, Amber
That's not why you were
invited on.
-It's partially why she wa
-That brings me to you, Seth
Roll the clip, Wally.
-Scollins, I do cue cards.
-You, too?
Seriously?
Somebody roll it.
-I mean, look at your outfit
You look like Mike Scollin
in a Zoom meeting.
-Unbelievable!
That's not even the type
of tank I like.
Those sleeves are clearly cut.
-Uh-huh.
-Well, Seth, you know what els
could use some clear cuts?
"A Closer Look."
-You about finished, pal?
-Nope.
Seth, do you know why I wear
a tank top on Zoom?
-I don't know. 'Cause you don'
think things through?
-I wear a tank top on Zoom for
the little kid watching at hom
who clearly does not
have the arms
to pull something like that off,
but he does it anyway.
-Sorry. How is a kid watchin
our Zoom meeting?
-I do it for the little kid in
the Midwest who, all his life,
has been told he needs to hide
his weird chest hair.
-What little kid has chest hair?
-I don't know.
He's like Italian.
-Scollins.
-Seth, tank tops
aren't just for lifeguards
or stepdads
or guys who want you to know
"If you can read this,
my old lady fell off."
They're for Scollins'
and Karnells' --
-Another writer who wears
tank tops but gets a free pass
-And, of course, the folks
who just don't feel like
getting dressed for a Zoom
meeting, God bless them.
-Okay, Mike, I hate
to cut you off --
-Was that a --
-It was.
-All right. We're done here.
We're done.
-Hey, Mike?
-Yeah?
-Tanks!
-I hate you.
-Mike Scollins,
ladies and gentlemen!